welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Thomas pogey he's the director of the
global justice program at the Macmillan
Center and is the lightener professor of
philosophy and international affairs at
Yale University professor pogey has
published widely on Kant and moral and
political philosophy including various
books on Rawls and global justice he
currently heads an international team
effort to blueprint and create the
health impact fund which will work to
improve access to advanced medicines for
the poor worldwide professor pogey is
also president of academic stand against
poverty an independent global
organization that aims to eradicate
severe poverty worldwide by leveraging
the knowledge and standing of academics
in order to influence policy and public
attitudes today we talk with Professor
pogey about his new book poverty and the
Millennium Development Goals a critical
look forward
welcome professor pogey yes sir it's
very nice to have you back on the show
with us let's begin with your book
please give us an overview of it yeah so
I should say it's an edited book it's a
collection of 10 essays which discuss
our experience with the Millennium
Development Goals these goals were
adopted at the end of the year 2000
that's why they're called the Millennium
Development Goals and they were
basically setting the course for how the
world's governments were going to make
sure that poverty would be diminished or
as they say eradicated hunger disease
various deprivation and now the 15 years
up the 31st of December 2015 was the
deadline for the Balam Development Goals
and they were replaced as you probably
know in September by the sustainable
development goal
which will govern the next 15 years and
so this is a very very good time we
thought to look back on the experience
with the Millennium Development Goals
and to see what we can learn about the
forthcoming sustainable development
goals so tell us a little bit about the
people who contributed the articles to
the book well we had a preponderance of
southern authors in fact and they where
to some extent revealing their
experience in their various countries
with the Development Goals Brazil for
example some South Asian countries and
so from basically a good smattering of
the African countries yes Africa but
also some northern authors and so we
have for example some very detailed
commentary so the Brazilian contribution
was talking in particular about how one
Educational Development Goal had pushed
things in a good direction for some
people but had overlooked another
crucial group of people namely people
who did not get a primary education when
they were supposed to get it in the
early years and are now getting
schooling very late in life and it's
essentially governments are incentivized
because they want to look good relative
to the Millennium Development Goals and
sent device to do certain things but
they're also thereby
the attention is diverted from other
things that are also important and that
they might also do so that's one
important lesson that when you formulate
these goals just think about them as
incentives
what would governments do that are
single-mindedly focused on developing
good numbers having good good-looking
numbers what might they do that could be
counterproductive unintended
consequences okay we'll get into that in
a minute let's talk about what the
actual Millennium Development Goals are
can you tell us about some of them sure
the the headline goal goal number one
was to eradicate poverty and hunger
with an immediate goal by 2015 to half
them and here they took the year 1990 as
a baseline and said that we want to have
the proportion of the population in the
developing countries that are suffering
from extreme poverty and hunger and so
had a 25 year period if you ask me I
thought this was somewhat under
ambitious to take 25 years to solve on
behalf the problem that is so massive
and severe but anyway that was the goal
and then there was annual reporting on
the Millennium Development Goals and
what they have come up with in the end
is that as far as extreme poverty is
concerned we have way over fulfilled the
target basically achieved the two-thirds
reduction and with regard to hunger we
have achieved roughly a 45 percent
reduction in the proportion where we
should have achieved a 50 percent
reduction but it's very crucial here to
look behind the numbers and how they
were generated okay let's let's do that
tell us about the numbers yeah so let me
start with hunger and what happened with
the hunger goal is that initially in the
first many years of the Millennium
Development Goal period the hunger
numbers were actually going up in
absolute terms and there was the famous
incident then in the year 2009 when the
FAO which was in charge of keeping the
numbers announced that for the first
time in all of human history more than a
billion people were chronically
undernourished it was one point zero to
three or twenty three million more than
a billion and they started the campaign
saying we are mad as hell more than a
billion people hungry now that was in
the wake of food riots in about 28
countries developing countries you may
remember the Arab Spring was partly
caused by these or initiated by these
food riots and it was very unwelcome
news
for the World Bank because the World
Bank had for years and years been saying
that extreme poverty is falling like a
brick much faster than we had even
announced and so the few people in the
world who care about these things they
were looking at these numbers and saying
that can't be right how can hunger go up
and up and up
while extreme poverty is going down and
down and down we thought that hunger is
extreme poverty these are essentially
the same people and so what happened
then was that very quickly
the FAO was told to convene a panel of
experts and to realize it's methodology
for counting the hungry so what was the
problem
you know at that the problem of well it
was if you ask me again I think that
there was there were severe problems in
the methodology of the World Bank the
World Bank is using a money metric
poverty line where they convert from one
currency to the next in terms of the
prices of all the goods and services
right you are not using when you convert
you're not using the exchange rate that
you get at the bank because obviously a
person who has a dollar in India can buy
more with that dollar than what a person
can buy in the United States right so
what they use is purchasing power
parities so to give you an example a
dollar is worth about 60 rupees in India
but the World Bank is saying that about
16 rupees is sufficient to have as much
purchasing power as a dollar gives you
in the United States now that is true in
general if you buy the kind of stuff
that the population of India or the
United States is buying but if you are
very very poor then you buy only a very
small sub segment of all the goods and
services that go into the purchasing
power parity calculations and that very
small sub segment is essentially
foodstuffs basic foodstuffs and
basic foodstuffs it turns out are
cheaper in India than they are in the US
but not as much cheaper as the
purchasing powers of the World Bank
would suggest okay and so the World
Bank's tracking is really way off
because the World Bank in using consumer
price indices and purchasing power
parities to convert the anchoring u.s.
dollar of the Year 2005 into other years
and other currencies is distorting the
conversion and so I think that a lot of
that very dramatic fall in poverty was
due simply to the way the World Bank was
calculating and so I have little
confidence in the hunger numbers and
even less confidence in the poverty
numbers but given that they were both
calculated on the basis of a very poor
methodology it's not surprising that
they went in opposite directions but
what happened then was that the FAO with
the help of all these experts who were
convened was unveiling a whole new
methodology in the year 2012 okay and
the result of that was that the number
of hungry people in the year 1990 the
base year was increased a lot and the
number of hungry people in the later
years 2009-2010 was decreased a lot so
what had been a steadily rising poverty
trend suddenly became steadily falling
poverty trend and so it became not
exactly consistent with the World Bank's
numbers but at least it was going in the
right direction and that is again one of
the things that we criticize in the book
because we believed that this was
essentially done with hindsight and that
the new definition of chronic
undernourishment that the FAO is now
using is a really inappropriate
definition
they define undernourishment in terms of
dietary intake that's the first problem
that very often in poor countries people
have absorption problems so they may
take in the diet they may take in the
energy but it may not arrive in their
system because they have parasites or
they have a disease of the small
intestine okay which hampers the
absorption secondly the FAO is only
looking at the energy intake and of
course you could have enough energy
simply from drinking enough Coca Cola
but a human body needs much more than
just energy it needs for example
minerals vitamins and so forth and this
is not a small problem many many women
in the developing countries suffer from
anemia iron deficiency anemia
millions and millions of people many
people suffer from vitamin A deficiency
iodine deficiency insufficiency and so
many many people are undernourished even
though they get enough energy in tech
the third thing is that they said that
you have to take in enough energy which
is sufficient for a sedentary lifestyle
and that again is a distortion because
many people in the developing world may
have enough energy intake for a
sedentary lifestyle but do not get
enough energy for the lifestyle that
they actually have right and that's not
because they go to the gym a lot but
because their income depends on doing
hard labor right so housewives for
example they don't turn on the tab often
to get water they have to go to the
river or to the well and carry water on
their heads for long distances men are
working in the fields or are working in
construction or working as rickshaw
drivers and again they expending a lot
of energy I know from my own experience
when I go to the gym I count the
calories and I consume about 600 kilo
calories an hour in the
and so the 1,800 kilocalories that the
FAO things are sufficient well they are
sufficient if I just type all day long
but if I just go to the gym for only one
hour I'm at 2400 and of course people in
the developing world don't work just for
one hour they work the whole day long
and if they work let's say eight hours
and half the energy level that I consume
in the gym that would be an additional
1,800 kilocalories that would double
their energy need or energy consumption
and the fourth and final condition that
the FAO s definition includes is that
you have to be below that minimum energy
level for a sedentary lifestyle for over
a year before you count as
undernourished
and to defend that they say we realize
that having being below that level may
be stressful if it's below a year but we
focus very narrowly on nutritional
deficits that are detrimental to health
so in other words if you go below that
energy level of the sedentary lifestyle
for less than a year it's not
detrimental to health and that of course
is totally ridiculous
because as we all know from hunger
strikes and from famines people die in
45 to 60 years if they don't get enough
energy and so again the FAO definition
leaves out many many people at least out
those people who have absorption
problems those people who work hard
those people who have nutritional
deficits other than energy and those
people who have shorter periods so how
does that happen how how does such a
mistake like that happen well I surmise
and I have a little bit of anecdotal
evidence about that I surmise that this
is because the FAO got under a lot of
pressure they got under pressure
especially when they came out with this
big news more than a billion people
hungry they hung that from the windows
of the FAO headquarters in Rome it was
big news in 2009 and so it got a lot of
governments upset because governments of
course were very proud of their
globalization project and how it was
lifting all boats and helping especially
the poor and we would never engage in it
if it went helping the poor and so on
and so the FAO got under pressure and
felt they needed to do something now why
didn't the FAO hold they head up high
and say these are the numbers and you
better live with them and you have to
change your policies rather than me
change our numbers right well the FAO is
an intergovernmental organization their
leaders are appointed by governments
their budgets are decided by governments
about 58% of the FAO budget comes at
hawk where governments sort of it's not
the regular budget that they get
regularly but it's additional money that
they get for this or that project on an
ad-hoc basis and so it's very important
if you care about poor people and if you
care about the work that the FAO is
doing to be on good terms with
governments and if governments get
really displeased with you right they
will not give you money and so the FAO
people where I think in a very difficult
situation on the one hand they felt that
being honest and true to the poor meant
they had to defend their numbers and say
this is what's really happening in the
world hunger is getting worse on the
other hand if you want to keep up your
good work and get the cooperation of
governments you feel that maybe you have
to betray the numbers and just give the
government's what they want so that they
give you what you need to is like a
catch-22 how do you get around that but
the answer is very obvious we cannot
leave the measurement of progress
to these weak vulnerable politically
exposed intergovernmental agencies
because we put them in an impossible
position what do we have universities
for right we have fantastic experts on
food on hunger on poverty in
universities we have an existing network
of universities that spans the globe of
people who are working together already
who are in the same discipline who
peer-review one another's work we could
easily create a poverty measurement and
the nourishment measurement operation
the network of people that is much
better than anything the FAO can field
and more importantly it would be
independent
these are first-rate academics who have
big reputations to lose and they would
deliver the correct verdict without fear
or favor they would not be easily
manipulated by governments into changing
their tune just to make the numbers look
better is that one of your findings in
your book one of the suggestions that we
make I think it's a very important thing
to press and here you see how for we're
going for the SDGs we have an important
message right let the SDGs be different
let the measurement be taken out of the
hands of the people who are doing the
work let the FAO be the leader on the
work on the ground let them lead the
effort to fight hunger and
undernutrition
but the observation the monitoring of
that fight how it's going let that be
done by an independent objective agency
so that the world really knows that make
sense yes
what are some of your other findings
well it's hard to summarize because
there are a lot of different things but
maybe I say one or two more things that
are interesting for the viewers perhaps
to think about so one of the things that
actually I contributed to the volume is
the thought that if you think about
these Development Goals you are
systematically
thinking in a way that's quite different
from the way we often think about these
matters of deprivation maybe in human
rights terms and so I reflect upon the
difference between the goals language
and the rights language okay the goals
language says basically here is
something that we want to attain in the
future and let's just walk in the right
direction and keep going and sooner or
later we'll get to our goal the rights
language says here are people who are
suffering severe deprivation z-- their
human rights are unfulfilled they have a
right that immediate action be taken to
fulfill their needs so for example under
nutrition or extreme poverty these are
the objects of human rights in the
Universal Declaration in the
international covenants and so on and so
something needs to be done immediately
so in a sense the goal language is
watering down humanity's commitment to
eradicate deprivation and to drive that
home just imagine for example FDR
Roosevelt had said in 1941 you know the
horrible things are being done by the
Nazis they're over running countries in
Europe they are putting hundreds of
thousands of people into concentration
camps we should set the goal of having
the number of people suffering by 1960
in nineteen years or something like that
I mean that would have been a pretty
ridiculous thing to say if people's
human rights are being violated you
can't sort of make that a goal and say
yeah we do a little bit every day and we
say get it down and so I think that
again we were too easily sucked into the
language of goals and thereby appeased
with regard to demanding immediate full
action and you know the thing what is
really heartbreaking about these
problems of deprivation of poverty of
undernourishment of disease is that in
economic terms these problems are tiny
you know at the cost of invading Iraq
you could abolish
hunger pensee
poverty worldwide very easily it is
economically a small problem and in
human terms it's still half of humanity
are living on the brink of
life-threatening deprivation and today
with today's technology is
administrative capacities economic
wherewithal we could wipe these problems
out and I think we should i completely
agree
why do you think we are not wiping them
out since it is possible well I think
that politicians for better or worse
think that this is something that
nobody's really going to reward them for
and to the contrary voters may feel
restive if too much money is spent
abroad you see it for example with the
promise that was made in the 1970s where
all the developed countries promised
they would spend 0.7% of their gross
national product on development
assistance a few countries have reached
that target Britain very recently
Finland Sweden Norway
I think Denmark maybe the Netherlands at
some point but not anymore but the vast
majority of countries has never reached
that goal never gotten anywhere near the
United States is sort of hovering in the
teens even I mean way below 0.7
somewhere around zero point one nine one
eight something like that so this is
simply that it's too easy for
nationalist politicians to step forward
and to say the government is giving away
the store you know they are giving all
your text money to foreigners and then
of course you start talking about the
corruption abroad and so on and that
it's sending money down a rat hole and
so forth and so I think that is the way
that it's just too easy for nationalist
politicians to block and to oppose this
kind of move and frankly the you know
few politicians really care enough
politicians are for the most part
interested in their own careers in their
own success politically and when they
win and when they have power they try to
preserve that power and they don't
really think about the morally most
urgent issues so in terms of the
sustainable development goals that have
been developed what are your thoughts on
those well the sustainable development
goals are very different they are much
much longer so you have instead of 18
targets you have 169 targets Wow the
MDGs were eight goals and 18 targets so
here we have 17 goals in 169 targets so
it's a very very long list and it is a
more comprehensive list which again has
some of the old goals included in it but
also a lot of other new things and one
thing that is especially noteworthy and
important is that you have inequality as
a specific goal that inequality should
be reduced the goal is then watered down
by one of the targets which says that
the reduction of inequality should have
begun before 2030 so inequality can
still go up until 2029 and then it
should which is really lame you know we
should think about inequality right now
and we should certainly certainly aim to
have less inequality in the world both
international and international in 2030
than we have today
so but anyway the SDGs at least have
talked about inequality they talk about
illicit financial flows a very important
topic that a lot of money is being
sucked out of poor countries with the
help of tax havens corrupt law firms
accounting firms financial advisers and
so on important multinational
corporations as in the meantime we all
have learned pay very little taxes in
the u.s. very little in Europe but guess
how much they pay in the poorer
countries who are much more defenseless
and much less able to resist right they
pay no taxes they basically shift all
their profits into tax havens and at
last count the multinational
corporations together have about 2.3
trillion dollars sitting in tax havens
completely untaxed waiting to spend that
money in ways you know but certainly
trying to avoid forever paying taxes
right many companies are now trying to
use inversions where they buy a company
abroad and then shift their headquarters
to the company they've bought so Pfizer
is currently doing that a big
pharmaceutical company trying to become
a non-us company and thereby permanently
to avoid paying taxes on the accumulated
money in tax havens so that's a problem
that the SDGs at least flag they mention
it they don't FEMA ties it in an
appropriate way but at least it's in
there and so and then of course the
environment the name sustainable
development goals already suggests that
there is a concern with the environment
and at least it gets mentioned ok so
ultimately what do you hope your book
will do the book I hope it will educate
citizens because we as citizens have a
responsibility to think about what is
being done in our names right we live in
a democratic society our government acts
in the name of the people of the country
and we are responsible for what the
government does which means we also have
to supervise we have to know what the
government does and supervise it and if
it is not morally appropriate what the
government is doing or immoral or wrong
we have to speak out and we have to say
not in our name don't do that and that
is true of course as everybody
understands with regard to Foreign Wars
that our government may be involved in
but it is just as true with regard to
economic rules that our government may
be involved in negotiating with other
countries and here of course it is to be
said that the US government is still by
far the strongest government in the
world in international negotiations and
so it matters a great deal
what negotiating position our government
is taking and we mustn't let that be
influenced
solely by the big corporations which of
course are interested only in their own
bottom line we have to make sure that
our government stands for justice and
stands for the common good of humankind
and defends also the interests of the
poorest human beings who really have
nobody else to speak up for them right
because their own governments are often
corrupt and in any case quite powerless
to intervene meaningfully in
international negotiations okay thank
you very much for being here with us and
sharing your work you're very welcome
Marilyn it was a pleasure thank you for
more information about Professor pogey
and his research please visit our
website at macmillan report Yale edu be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you